[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROMIN IRANI: Hello, and welcome
to this talk on Developing
Faster for GCP with Cloud Code.
I'm Romin Irani.
I work as a developer
advocate for Google Cloud.
Let's get started
with our talk on how
to make life easier
for any developer
currently building out cloud
native applications on Google
Cloud.
First up, it's important to
understand what a developer
workflow looks like.
What are the tasks
that a developer
does during a typical
development cycle?
Usually, it goes like this,
code, build, test, integrate,
and deploy.
The reason I mention
this is that it
is important to understand
which of these steps
does Cloud Code exactly
fit into and how
it can help the developer
be more productive.
So let's visualize this
in more detail with what
we call the inner and
outer development loops.
This slide shows the inner
and outer development loops.
These loops are all about the
individual developer-- that's
you.
It really represents
your day-to-day work.
Typically, it's about
coding out a feature,
building it, testing it,
then maybe you find a bug.
And then you repeat
the cycle over and over
again until it's ready
for the outer loop.
Once a developer pushes
their code to the outer loop,
it begins the process of getting
integrated into the larger code
base, making sure everything
is ready before finally
releasing it to the world.
That's what these
loops are all about.
But there are many challenges.
And let's face it, as developers
we want to stay in our ID
and write code.
But that's not always
the case, as you
know from your experience.
There are too many
distractions always keeping us
from writing our code.
Let me take you through some
of the most common challenges.
The first challenge is
about context switching.
You have to switch
between multiple tools,
like the ones you see over
here, and even environments.
For example, your local cluster
versus your remote cluster.
The next challenge is
about too many tools.
For example, you may use
minikube to run Kubernetes
locally; Helm to define
Kubernetes Infra,
with programmatic charts;
Jib for easily containerizing
Java applications; Skaffold
Pipelines to build, push,
and deploy apps; Docker
to run containers locally,
Kube Cuddle, a set of
client-interface commands
for Kubernetes.
So as you can see,
there are so many tools
that developers
need to learn about.
And last, but not
the least, frameworks
like Kubernetes are not easy.
This is a really
complex environment.
It is difficult to start off.
And there is a lack
of sample applications
that could get you
started easily.
Those challenges are the ones
we want to eliminate or reduce.
And this is exactly where
Cloud Code comes in.
What it gives you is
a set of ID plug-ins
to make the development
loop faster.
The idea is to keep developers
in the ID, less distraction,
less context switching, exactly
what we want as developers,
to stay in the code.
Most importantly,
there is support
for the full development cycle.
We also want to give
samples and configurations
to get you started fast.
And that is what Cloud
Code provides you with.
In short, Cloud Code
is a set of ID plug-ins
which are available for
a lot of popular IDs,
like JetBrains
Visual Studio Code.
It is also integrated into
Google Cloud Shell Editor,
should you want
to use Cloud Shell
as your primary
development machine.
This brings me
back to the diagram
we saw earlier about the inner
and outer development loops.
Now it should be clear to
you what Cloud Code does.
It focuses on the
inner development loop.
It's here to make that
whole loop faster and more
streamlined, so that
as developers we
do what we love the most,
which is to keep developing.
I would now like to highlight
key Cloud Code features.
First up, speeding up
Kubernetes development
to reduce context
switching and moving
from one tool to another.
And it's important that
development and debugging
remains within the ID.
It also allows you to
manage your clusters,
whether they are local or
remote, all from within the ID.
Let's talk about deployments.
You can actually scroll
through and explore
Kubernetes clusters,
your deployments,
see the different resources
that are out there,
and make changes
right there in the ID.
Whether it's local or remote,
Cloud Code has you covered.
GKE and Cloud Run,
these services
are fully supported
in Cloud Code.
And you can deploy these
services with a few clicks,
as we'll see in the demos.
Let's come to YAML.
That's not an easy thing
to get started with.
There are hundreds of objects
and complicated syntax
structures.
No one remembers that.
Not even I remembered it.
So what Cloud Code gives you
is authoring support, which
means code completion, linting,
and more than 400-plus resource
definitions with autocomplete,
and even checks for valid
values if needed.
Finally, and importantly, we
have integrated Cloud APIs
right within Cloud Code.
Which means you can
explore the different APIs,
enable them for your project,
browse through the API
documentation, take a
look at sample code,
and integrate it
into your projects.
I'll give you a glimpse
of that in the demos.
So let's see all of
this in action now.
The first demonstration
will show you
how we can take a sample
Kubernetes application
and deploy it to
a local cluster.
But utilizing tools like
Skaffold behind the scenes you,
will see that the
inner development
loop that we talked
about is set up
to constantly watch and
monitor for code changes,
and redeploying the
application for you if needed.
You'll also see how we can view
the clusters, deployments, make
changes as necessary, along
with switching environments,
whether it's local,
that is minikube,
or remote, that is GKE.
The first demo that I'm
going to demonstrate
will show you how
Cloud Code makes
the whole inner development
loop process more efficient.
So I'm right now in Visual
Studio Code with Cloud Code
installed.
And as you can see, Cloud Code
gives you various commands.
You can create a new
application and you
can work with Kubernetes
and Cloud Run services.
Some of these options are also
available on this left panel,
which you see over here.
And you can navigate
in that manner.
I've got a sample application
opened up over here
and it's a Kubernetes
application, a Java
Spring based application, that
has the following architecture,
as you can see--
a service, a
deployment, and a pod.
And when you hit that
particular you are in,
it's going to show
you a simple web
page that says it's running.
Now in terms of the files,
the key thing to look at
is the Skaffold or YAML.
This is what goes on
behind the scenes.
And Skaffold really
has multiple steps
for build, deploy, and more.
So if you look at
the Skaffold YAML
you will see that there
are different steps,
as I mentioned.
There's a build step,
there's a deploy step.
At each step, you can
determine what other parameters
you want to provide.
So for example, the
build one has got--
that we'll be using
in the Jib tool
to compile and build our Java
application as a container
image.
Similarly, the
deploy step mentions
which particular folder it
can look for, the YAML files.
We can also define multiple
profiles if you want to.
Now what we are
going to do is I'm
going to go to the Cloud
Code Kubernetes option, which
you see over here.
And I'm going to try and
run this application.
But before that, let me quickly
show to you that in clusters--
I've got two clusters over here.
One is the minikube local
cluster that I've started.
And the other one
is a cluster in GKE.
You can switch at any
particular point in time
from one cluster to
another while this
set as active cluster option
that you see over here.
To run this
application now locally
on minikube, what
I'm going to do
is simply click on the Run
button that you see over here.
When you do that, it asks you to
select a launch configuration.
I'll go with the
default for now,
but you can create your own
launch configurations also.
I'm going to click on Run.
What this does is
that it kicks off
the entire process, where it
will set up the connectivity
to minikube.
It will also then begin
with all the steps
around building the
container image,
deploying it, setting up port
forwarding, and much more.
So as you can, see the
Skaffold tool is powering
this thing behind the scenes.
So as you can see
now here, we are
going through multiple steps.
We are at build containers.
And now it's also deploying
the pod and the whole thing
to the cluster.
It's also set up now
to port forwarding
and it's streaming
the application logs.
So as you can see,
it's got a URL that
is opened up for us over here.
And if I click on
that, it shows me
that the application is
running and everything is fine.
What I'm going to do is just
go back to Cloud ID for now
and I'll also show you
that you can actually
inspect all the
resources in the cluster.
So in this minikube
cluster you can
see that we've got one
deployment, as you can see,
and we've got that
one single pod that
is there in this application.
For any of these resources,
you can also get more details.
So for example,
for our deployment
we can view the
logs if you want.
And those show up over here.
So inside the deployment
logs or even pod logs,
you can take a look at those.
You can also see
that, for example,
the desired replicas
is set as one.
We can edit it
directly over here.
So I'm going to go and click
this and make it, let's say,
three.
And click on Enter.
What happens now is
the additional pods
are getting launched.
And you can see all three
of them are running now.
So it's as simple as
editing it over here
and seeing those
changes take effect.
For the pods, again,
you can get the logs,
you can even get a
terminal if you want
and inspect the
files if you want to.
So that's another
great feature that's
available right
within the ID itself.
Now the next thing I'm going to
do is, that while all of this
is running, I am going to go
and make some code changes.
So I'm going to go to the Java
file and that text where it
says it's running, I'm just
going to go and make a small
change here and change it
to "local-it's running,"
and I'm going to save this file.
When I do that,
let's see the output.
The change has happened.
And it's beginning
this whole process now
of kicking off that
building, the deploying.
Then we can go to
that particular URL
and we will be able to see
that the change has happened.
The next thing I
want to show you
is how easy it is to work
with YAML in Cloud Code.
So for example, in
this same project,
we've got our different
Kubernetes manifest files here.
So what I'll do is I'll go
ahead and create a new file.
And let's create our
sample YAML out here.
So for example, as I type in,
it shows me different options.
And it has support for hundreds
of resource definitions.
So, for example, if
I take deployment,
it helps me fill this out.
Let's say we do my app.
Then the next one is an
image and even a port.
Even if you make some mistakes--
for example, the port, which
is a value, if I put some
wrong value, as you can see,
and hover over it,
it tells you that it
was expecting an integer.
This shows you how easy it is to
work with YAML with Cloud Code
extension.
In the second part,
what I'm going to show
you is how you can do debugging
in the local environment.
To do that, I've stopped the
service that I had started,
or the application.
And what I'm going to do
is, instead of doing a run,
I'm going to go, and go ahead,
and do that debug application
thing.
So when I do that, let's
first go and start it.
So I'm going to just say I'm
going to debug this application
and run it from the same
launch configuration.
Once I do that, it's again
going to create the same process
of ensuring that the
connectivity is there
to the local cluster.
And then it begins the whole
process of bootstrapping.
So then the whole
build, the deployment.
And it's going to
start up the service.
OK, so the deployment
is complete now.
And we've got--
the port forwarding
is also up and running for us.
And the whole thing is
set up in debug mode also.
So first up, I will just go
and visit that particular URL
and see what happens.
So when I click on
that, everything
is back to what it was,
which is it's running.
And it'll just tell you the
statement that we had changed,
which was local,
and it's running.
Great.
So I'm going to go
back now to Cloud ID.
And I'm going to now put a
breakpoint over here at this
sentence, or at this statement,
which is string message,
"local-it's running."
Once I do that, I'm just going
to go back to the browser
and maybe refresh this.
So what this should do is, this
should go ahead and now break
into that particular statement.
So as you can see,
that's happened.
And in the local variables, you
can view the local variables.
Let's step through this
particular statement right now.
So if I just step
over it, you will find
that the variables are visible.
There you go.
And you can now set the
variables if you want to.
So let's do a small test.
I'm just going to look
at the value in this
and probably just
change one small value.
Instead of the dash,
I'll just right
click this, set the
value to, let's say,
to debug-- that is D.
Once I do that, all I'm
going to do now is simply
go ahead and say
run the rest of it.
So this will go and just
run the application.
And if I go back
to the browser, you
will see that it
took the change.
So this is how easily you can
do debugging within the Cloud ID
itself.
The second demo I have
for you is cloud APIs.
Cloud APIs can be
difficult to integrate,
but we have made it easier
by allowing you to view
these APIs all in one place.
You can zoom into
one of the cloud APIs
and see how to integrate
that into your project.
You can even enable the
APIs for your project.
You can check out the snippet
in your favorite programming
language and integrate
that snippet of code
in your application, which means
that the task of connecting
to a wide range of Google
APIs is made much easier,
since you can do all of
that within the ID itself.
Let's dive into this demo.
Welcome to the
second demo, where
I'll show you how Cloud
Code makes it easier
to integrate the
various Google Cloud
APIs into your application.
And what I wanted
to show you first
is that if you go to the Cloud
API section and the Cloud Code
extension you can take a look
at the various Cloud Code
APIs that are given over here.
You can select any particular
API that you would like.
And what it does is it
shows you a few things.
Initially, it shows you
how to get started with it.
So it's important
that if you want
to use a particular
API in your project,
you will need to enable it.
As you can see
over here, it even
says that this is the GCP
project that you are currently
having as the current
project you want to work on.
You can switch if you would
like or even create one.
It shows you that the enable
API button can be selected.
In a sense, you can enable the
API for this project, which
is not right now.
So you can do that from
right within the ID itself.
Alternately, it also
shows you, for example,
depending upon the programming
language that you have chosen
as your preference, it
gives you the dependencies
that you need to
install, depending
upon the programming language.
So for example, there's
Java, there's Node.Js.
It tells you what's the
package you need to install.
Similarly, Python, Go, and more.
And not just that, it even gives
you a particular code sample
that you can then integrate
right within your application.
So what I'm going to show
you is that, the sample
application that
I've got, it's going
to be using one of the
APIs, a secret manager API.
But first up, I'll
just also show you
that we've got secret manager
integration in Cloud Code
itself.
So over here in my
GCP project, I've
got two secret IDs
that I've created.
And there are my secret
and volume 1 password.
These are sample secrets
that I've created.
For volume 1
password, for example,
I've got version 1 of it.
And If I see its
value, I'll just set it
to a sample password, 123.
The point now is I'll be
integrating the secret manager
API into my application and then
using this value accordingly.
So the way I would
do this typically
is I would go to the Cloud
API section over here
and I'll search for, let's
say, the secret manager
API that's out there.
Once I select that, it
gives me those same details.
It's telling me that the API
for this particular project
is already enabled,
which is good.
It's also giving me how I
can set up the dependency,
so that it helps me
to build the project
or application correctly.
So these dependencies
that are there--
for example, since I'm using
Java Spring application,
I've already taken these
dependency snippets
that it has given and have put
them into the Maven form file,
as you can see.
So one of them is over here
and the other dependency
that you saw, I've
put them right here.
Next up is that it's telling
you to try a code sample,
the code snippets that
I was talking about.
So if you go over there,
I need to print out
the secret for a specific
version, the metadata.
So the sample is
given over here.
That means get a secret version.
And if I click
that, it's already
giving me sample code
that I can use and save
tons of time in order to
just integrate with this API.
As you can see, it's telling
me all I need to provide
is the project ID, the
secret ID, and the version.
So I've taken all of this
and in the particular Java
file I've created that.
So I'll just show
you that quickly.
So I've created a sample
file called Access Secret
Version in which whatever code
you saw, right now sample,
I've just taken it as is,
and just used the values
that you see out here.
And then all I'm
doing is I'm just
printing it out by calling
this particular code.
I can just test it out.
So I can just run it even
locally and check out
the integration.
So I will just launch this
particular application.
And once it's all
up and running,
I can just hit that
particular Home page URL
and see whether it's able
to access the secret version
and get me the value.
So now that it is
up, all I need to do
is visit that particular
URL, which I'm clicking now.
And there you go.
It's got the value for
the particular secret ID
that I was interested in and
it's printed it out here.
This shows you how easy it is to
integrate the respective cloud
APIs within your application.
Thank you very much
for listening in.
We hope that you've
got a good idea now
of how Cloud Code ID plug-ins
can help make the development
process for cloud
native applications
on Google Cloud
easier and faster.
Have a good day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]